what do you think is uh going to happen
in miami do we have any estimates of the
economic impact of 400 million 400
million dollars in in around miami yeah
all right what's going on with f1 how
how's this gonna play out this weekend
it's gonna be massive this is going to
be so dope f1 in miami is going to be
massive they're calling it the east
coast monaco now west wes the westmont
monaco west you know monaco west so uh
it's gonna be
probably the largest formula one race of
the year austin texas had 400 000 people
show up to race weekend last year which
was the largest formula one event in
history formula one's been around for 75
years that's crazy last year in austin
texas in the united states where their
fan base is in nearly i mean the races
get a million viewers it's a very
european heavy rich person like to be
completely honest kind of stuffy
thing and then netflix happened and it
feels like america was like yo nascar
that's your grandfather's thing yeah
this is the future and they're just
something
so they had 400 000 people come and i
think 70 of them were it was their first
race
wow so that's how impactful netflix was
and and the sport in general just
because one of the other things too like
bernie wasn't allowing the teams to use
social media
so like
like come on you all need cars you all
need phones right so like now the the
the drivers are all active on social
media they have massive audiences teams
et cetera it's like this self-fulfilling
thing right so they added from no one
claims they added 70 million fans last
year i don't know exactly how they're
calculating that but whatever and then
the average age has moved down
dramatically i think it used to be in
the high 30s or low 40s the average age
of a fan now it's low 30s or high 20s
right so it's moved down dramatically
given all the other sports leagues so
now they're coming to miami and they
just added another race in las vegas the
third race
this might be
ballin miami uh for example
they literally created the track for the
weekend so that's how much money they're
gonna make doing it right like the so
the average race
it varies depending on what it costs to
put on uh but the rights alone the right
to host the race so formula one the way
to think about it is it's like it's a
super asset like business they don't
actually own any of the other stuff what
they do is they license you the brand
essentially and then an event
coordinator an event company puts on the
race so
uh miami they're basically the event
organizer they buy the right to host the
race from formula one and then they
organize everything right you have to
build the specifications how formula
wants it how the fia wants it and so
forth but ultimately you're in charge of
all that so that could cost anywhere
from 5 million to 90 million depending
on the track it's historical
significance etc so they're paying
somewhere in between there my guess
would probably be somewhere on the lower
end of that maybe 20 30 40 million in
that range and uh they put on the race
the race is insane this year they have
tom brady's coming michael jordan's
coming serena williams venus williams
the pomp boys yeah david beckham we're
going so yeah you know like uh but it's
gonna be massive for context the the
tickets are more expensive than the
super bowl right now the tickets to the
f1 race in miami are more expensive than
the super bowl tickets the average
ticket yeah because so even a ticket
just to get in right now for the race on
sunday general admission where you don't
even have a seat literally you're just
allowed to walk around the campus and
like you'll catch some cars in like
certain areas uh or like five six seven
hundred dollars a seat is like fifteen
hundred or two thousand almost a premium
seat like the paddock club or the
champions club can go anywhere from like
10 to 15 to 20 000. wow yeah so insane
that that is uh
that's a crazy number and you know
what's even crazier actually formula one
this shows you how insignificant the
business was in the united states when
they took over
the right to broadcast it was initially
free
for espn
and then espn paid now espn pays five
million dollars a year
that is that is for people that don't
know that's literally nothing compared
to what they pay i mean amazon pays a
billion dollars a year for one nfl game
a week right
literally one thursday night football
they pay a billion dollars a year for
and espn is paying five million dollars
to host 23 25 races whatever it is uh
each sunday on their network
formula one now says this last year that
deal they want to get 75 million a year
and it's like the difficult part about
this well so the difficult part is you
can't it's difficult to run commercials
right it's uh there's no commercials in
the broadcast right now so it's
difficult to monetize for espn and so
forth but like if you're netflix if
you're esp even espn like put that [ __ ]
on espn plus
pay 75 million dollars put on there
you'll 100
netflix pays 30 million dollars per
episode of their most popular shows
literally per episode it's like why
would you not pace 50 million 60 million
70 million dollars and put it on why
don't they just do the ads around like
put the little boxes they can that's
what that's what they do for like nascar
and indycar and stuff like that
sometimes so you could do that uh i
think that's probably we're just saying
we go into commercial we'll be back
yeah even 30 seconds or whatever i mean
fans don't want that obviously but it is
what it is but the audience has grown
tremendously they used to get 400 000
viewers now they're over a million for
most races that are the timing's
obviously difficult too but if it's a
morning race or a time that works for
america it's over a million viewers now
which is pretty significant yeah what do
you think is uh going to happen in miami
do we have any estimates of the economic
impact of 400 million 400 million
dollars in in around miami yeah
that's what they claim and they think
that this is going to be as big as um i
mean that's a super bowl yeah they think
it's going to be as big as uh monaco
uh yeah so like
the thing about monaco is monaco is like
a spectacle and they pay the least out
of anyone to host the race because it's
historical and it's significant it's
beautiful obviously all that kind of
stuff i've been to monaco you have not
the race though right no not the race
yeah so the the race though the part
about the race that's frustrating to a
lot of fans though is it's really boring
because the cars have become super heavy
uh they're obviously faster they're
wider et cetera and it's really hard to
pass each other on the monaco track
because i mean it's a street track it's
just in the roads so uh this should be
more entertaining hopefully if the track
performs well uh and i think like the
other thing too is monaco always had the
benefit because there was never like a
massive racing in the united states so
celebrities would go to monaco because
that was like the the famous race right
that's where they want to be seen
in miami for american celebrities yeah
really yeah
damn i mean lebron james is going yeah
but this is wow and uh if you if you uh
so the track is obviously insane they
literally built this
like a few months ago they had the the
tennis courts still up for the miami
open like look at this campus it's
absolutely insane and all of this is
coming down the only thing that's
staying is the actual track itself right
so the asphalt is staying everything
else is coming look at these yachts bro
they got yachts there they're trying to
beat monaco they literally put fake
water
that's fake water they got yachts put in
the face
water it's literally just like printed
on there and they brought these yachts
they didn't pay for the yacht supposedly
i think oh that's not real water no it's
fake water it's like it's like a yeah
it's like a it's like a it's like a
stage basically and it's a cardboard
cutout essentially think of it like that
and the boat the boats are real the
yachts are real and they're like uh
they're people that are trying to market
their yachts a ticket to get on that
boat it's like 12 grand you get bottle
service when you watch the race
and it's all it's a yacht and fake water
yeah i mean look at this track dude this
thing is insane and uh and they got the
sun the sunset happening i don't know if
we can pull up the last picture of just
what it looked like previously look at
this that's what it looked like before
yeah i've been there before that's
literally what it looked like and now
this is what it looks like and they're
going to leave the track they're going
to leave the asphalt they're going to
take down everything else because they
need the parking for football season
damn
how much do you think it costs to build
oh millions yeah well of course millions
but like man
yeah i mean
i don't know it's insane though